you listen to the podcast in Hungary
Isn't that cool I think I just love that
yeah
um were you familiar with my work prior
to the podcast
yeah so
no it's okay it's okay don't have to be
ashamed it's we we're probably never
seen there we didn't have like late
night on TV so the only thing though all
the things I know about you it's from
the podcast yes okay so you know that I
picked up you know that I'm a
megalomaniac yeah
no I am um one of the biggest stars in
the world wow from television uh I had a
show
yeah okay I'm gonna amend what I said
I'm gonna change what I say
um I had a late night show
um and uh for a number of years and uh
so that's how many people know me but
it's interesting that you only know me
from this podcast but as long as you
know me my ego is satisfied
that's good yeah
um so that's uh that's a victory for me
yeah I think congratulations yeah
congratulations it doesn't bother you at
all that you had this whole body of work
for 28 years and she doesn't know
anything about it well maybe have you
ever watched The Simpsons
nope oh my god well I think this
conversation's over oh there's some
Simpsons that did it yeah I can't speak
to you if you haven't watched The
Simpsons have you ever watched any of
his online clips from the show like Sona
remotes with Sona and thing
I've watched some interviews and then
when I found out I'm going to be talking
to you right
I Googled you so what I'm hearing is you
like coding but only if Sona and I are
involved
that's not what I'm hearing I think
you're missing you're missing the
headline here Gorly the headline here is
that she knew nothing Ben found out that
she was going to be interviewed by me so
she Googled me
how many podcasts do you randomly apply
to be oh yeah this one just you didn't
even care
you were like that's not true I don't
care every episode okay well that's nice
that's nice but it's nice that you
Google me I want to tell you a true
story which is sometimes uh I sit I'll
be invited to a dinner party and I'll
sit be seated with some people I don't
know and then it becomes very clear to
me within minutes that they Googled me
on the way to no no it is no no I mean
they knew kind of who I was or whatever
but they'll start saying things it's
just so funny they'll just start talking
to me in a way and it's clear that they
were reading this off of Google not five
minutes ago while they were waiting for
the valet to park the car I remember
when Adam asked me to work on this
podcast I had to Google yeah I did too
before my first my interview with you I
Googled you okay well you're all awful
people
yeah okay yeah you hosted a show but all
you did a lot of other stuff too that I
didn't know about you didn't know I was
a bodybuilder okay you didn't know that
I was also a successful eye surgeon
Veronica anyway we're forgetting about
our friend here Veronica Veronica
welcome I I it's okay that you Googled
me and I'm glad that you listened to the
podcast and I'm glad that we're friends